(light whimsical music)
- The world at the end
of the decade will have
eight billion people.
They'll be carrying 20
billion mobile devices,
and we just want to
know how we can keep up
with that huge amount of information,
and rather than let someone
else think of the new thing,
we thought what would it be like
if we were to change the world.
Moore's Law is actually
not a physical law,
it's an observation.
We take devices, in every generation,
and we try and make them half the size
that they were before.
The observation, made by Gordon Moore,
was that about every 18 to 24 months,
the number of transistors you could fit
into a given piece of
silicon semi-conductor
was going to double.
The industry has chased
this as that benchmark
for continuous improvement
and that's gonna stop.
Things are gonna start to slow down
on that Moore's Law of improvement
because things are just getting too small
to get any smaller.
So, we find ourselves running
out of computation technology
that has lifted our
productivity as an economy
for at least 50 years.
What if everything changed all at once?
(light whimsical music)
I'm overseeing a project
we call The Machine.
The Machine will be far more powerful
than today's computers and
consume far less energy.
It will allow us to extract
insights from enormous data sets
in real time.
We'll actually have a tiny laser source
and they'll be shooting
photons between each other
creating much greater
capacity for information,
transmission at a much, much lower power.
My name is Kirk Bresniker,
and I'm a Fellow here at
Hewlett Packard Laboratories,
and I get to dream up crazy things,
and say, "You know what?”
"We're gonna do this."
We want to show that we
have a really good shot
at surpassing the current
level of performance.